[Music]
you
good evening good evening I'm Alexander
Rose I'm the executive director here at
the long now foundation and as some of
you may know we've been kind of self
funding the video and podcasts of this
series for the past year but an
interesting story that happened is that
about three years ago our own developer
recommended this payment system called
stripe to do all of our membership and
all of our donations through and we
switched it over and it's been fantastic
and it saved us lots of time and and
money and then what we didn't know is
that Patrick and John Collison the
founders of stripe have been coming to
these events unbeknownst to us and then
we got to know them and through that
relationship they've decided to sponsor
the podcast and video for the series as
well as the interval and so we wanted to
welcome them to the community and thank
them for all their support thank you and
as many of you know one of the things we
do in this series is a what we call a
long short a short film that exemplifies
long term thinking in some way and this
this months comes to us suggested by our
own Danielle Engelmann who many of you
know through membership emails and
announcements of this series but it's a
it's a pretty amazing video that was
taken through the course of one year
about one tree enjoy
so that's Italy and those wolves that
are back in Italy I guess or our local
variety is coming back to California I'm
Stuart bran from the long now foundation
I feel like I should our speaker tonight
comes all away from the University of
York and England thanks to the
breakthrough Institute I use
participating and breakthrough dialogue
the next three days across the bridge at
Koval a point breakthrough I'm on the
board of it they are basically trying to
invent the next century of how
environmentalism can be more realistic
and our speaker was speaking of that
because he is exceptional on bringing
realism and I'm gonna get something for
a prop here I've been hearing about him
for a long time and then finally at the
age of how are you Chris you refuse this
to say this is first book and it's an
accomplished piece of work the quality
of the writing is true and good to the
comma you can sort of tell how much I
like a book by how much is dog-eared and
I think this is the closest we've gotten
to ground truth of what's going on with
basically the natural world that we've
had since Darwin Chris Thomas our
speaker really goes to the functional
dynamics as well as the ground truth of
what's happening oh this reflects a
lifetime of research by him much of it
in the field much of it doing
scholarship much of it traveling to
visit the various other field biologists
who are doing the work to get a sense of
what's really happening out there and
looking at it from an evolutionary
perspective which is the right along now
frame a birth
Chris Thomas
well Thank You Stuart and thank you for
the invitation to be here which is
wonderful and thank you the audience for
coming here well after that set up I'm
sorry you might as well go now because
it's going to be a disappointment to you
what I want to do is effectively to ask
this question and I think the question
is a reasonable one for us to ask we're
changing the world
in a huge wave every way you look at it
things are dying out we know that
environmental doom is closed in front of
us and I'm not going to deny the many
harms and things that are going wrong on
this planet from a biological
perspective and the common sense for
humans to try and reduce the rate at
which we change certain aspects of the
planet and so that we live in a world
that not only can sustain the human
population but is actually a planet that
we want to live on but it is also worth
asking of all of these changes that
we're reaching to the planet right now
is what species are taking advantage of
these changes is it generating new
diversity at the same time as it is
causing losses what are the processes
underpinning this and what might be the
long-term view so the long now Institute
likes to put a zero in front of its
dates thinking long term thinking ah
nothing at least several zeros are
required we really need to think long
term when we go to the biological world
because it's been running for billions
of years now and we're just a recent
invention of it we need to think what
are we doing to this planet and where
might it be heading in the future so
that's my question but first last let's
start with some doom and gloom because
that makes every environmentalist feel
deeply good inside
if we look at the last half billion
years 500 million years not very long in
terms of the history of life on Earth
but most of the big things like us well
or not quite so much like us but I'm
thinking of tryla bikes as being a bit
like us were in have been in existence
for this time period so we've seen these
so-called big five mass extinctions so
there's time running on the bottom axis
there and on the y axis going up there
we've got the number of families
paleontologists the fossil folks like to
look at numbers of families that have
been in existence partly because fossils
are not fossilized that things aren't
fossils fossilized that regularly so
most of the species that exist it have
never left a fossil behind at all or at
least not one that has been discovered
and partly if you've got a bit of a
fragment of an animal you can probably
tell what family it's in but not
necessarily what species so they tend to
count families so those big arrows going
down are when there have been big die
backs in the history of life the
so-called big five mass extinctions and
have also been lots of mini one a big
five
represents about 75% or more in some
cases up to about 95 percent of species
dying out in one relatively short period
but a short period might be a hundred
thousand years or a million years but
but a relatively brief in terms of this
total history and the question is then
are we doing the same now if we look at
birds it might be mainly from a species
living on oceanic islands for birds we
might already have got up to about 10
percent of species having died out
already two-thirds of them before about
1500 so extinction caused by humanity is
not just a recent thing of the
technological aid that we've become in
the last century or two but has been
going back quite a long time and the
question mark there is are we coming for
a big mass extinction and this wonderful
book by Betsy Kolber
I would strongly recommend the sixth
extinction out lies some of the key
driving factors which might be at risk
of exterminating species on this planet
and there is no doubt whatsoever that
the current rate of extinction is high
by on a geological timescale things are
dying out faster than normal if you
extrapolate the current rate somewhere
from a few thousand years to a few tens
of thousands of years in the future
we could end up with one of these mass
extinctions I don't think we're going to
get there partly because we as the
current generation of humans think this
is not the way we really want the future
of the planet to be and partly because
Nature is proving to be slightly more
resilient than some pessimists are
suggesting but what I'm not going to do
is to argue about the many declines that
are taking place declines can happen of
some things and simultaneously increases
of other things can take place it's
worth reminding ourselves in the long
history of life on earth over the last
few billion years but on average the
diversification process by which one
type of thing or one species if you like
turns into two or more different species
that on average of them very fact that
there's however many millions of species
there are on the planet is because on
average the rate of splitting into two
or more entities has slightly exceeded
the rate at which the previous entities
died out otherwise we wouldn't have this
diversity that we have today and so
we've got the bacteria on the left-hand
side they're the archaea that live the
things at the top which to most humans
we think they're the similar sorts of
things but they're very very unrelated
and then we've got on the right hand
side the so-called eukaryotes which is
most of the organisms that we are
familiar with including just a little
sort of pinprick on the edge of life on
Earth the large multi
things like plants and animals that we
recognize and although I have put my
favorite picture of coatis up there of
course most and I'm an entomologist I
should add and of course most
terrestrial animals at least to insects
much more important so I ask again are
we in line for a six mass origination so
we're definitely causing annex and
acceleration of the extinction rate no
one doubts that but after the previous
mass extinctions what you've seen is
this growth in biological diversity
again no one knows for these geological
time periods what the true time lag of
the restoration of diversity has really
been because is your units of families
like like a swallowtail butterfly is in
one family a monarch is in another
butterfly family well these things that
are as distinct as that out if to you
lot they probably all butterflies but I
could assure you they're quite different
but two families this can take tens of
millions of years before one species
that splits into two that the
descendants of these two species are so
dissimilar that they rank as different
biological families and so this appears
to take a long time for diversity to be
restored but we have the huge privilege
of the moment as well as the sadness of
living through at least a mini mass
extinction and we can ask the question
whether origination accelerates during
the period of speciation rather than
simply lagging after it
so is this happening well I'm going to
divide this into two sections it's not
just that I'm sunburned I think um I
think I slightly recolored the picture
because the gray york skies were we're
not very attractive anyway so when I was
a child so what I want to do is to
consider first of all the growth
ecological diversity and then later on
the talk go on to how their changes and
increases in some instances of
ecological diversity in the end is going
to turn out in to generate large numbers
of in additional species on this planet
so here when I was a child Mike that
mother was not very amused when I tried
to dig a hole to Australia she thought
it was we didn't have very large lawn at
the time and she thought that it was
unnecessary to devote quite such large
part of it to this experiment however as
a 50-something I'm admitting it now as a
50-something academic I decided I'd go
on a much more much easier adventure and
visit the Ice Age and so that is exactly
what I did now fortunately I have a
field which is a sort of wildlife meadow
but this is in early spring before it
started to grow up and so I decided to
dig a hole and you can see the different
layers of soil that I uncovered and this
reveals the first thing that I think is
really critically important about
biological life on our planet it
survives and lives where it is possible
for it to live at a particular time the
die processes of ecology as well as
evolution are dynamic and over the last
twenty thousand years which to me at
least see nowadays seems like a very
short period is that the biological
world has turned on its head time and
time again
now I'm really lucky to have these
geological deposits in my field so at
the bottom there you see Ice Age Lake
clays so 15 to 20 thousand years ago we
were at the heights of the last ice age
there was the in fact the City of York
is built on the gravels at the end of
the glaciers that were at the time over
large parts of northern England and
spread the whole way up to towards the
North Pole so there was this ice age
lake and that's an arctic char there
this is the sort of environment and you
find
although the species don't live
in this area any longer they all still
survive but in the Arctic then there was
a great big woosh when the water drained
out of this lake it was held in by a
huge glacier that blocked off the
melting ice and it formed this pool in
what is the Vale of York this enormous
pool of a lake when that drained it
exposed not only the clays but also lots
of sand and silts and in this ensuing
quite cold few thousand years about
12,000 years ago there were actually
sand dunes in this system as the sands
had had been deposited by the melting
glaciers and rivers piled up into a dune
system it was a bit like a sort of
prairie very cold in winter and at least
a bit warmer in the summer this thing
was grazed by mammoths and rhinoceros
and I still find it amazing to think
when I stand on my land as I
occasionally do and I try and think
through time in the very place that I
live to think that just 12,000 years ago
yes there really were rhinoceros here I
mean just amazing most of the
inhabitants of York and not particularly
interested in the fact that were a
rhinoceros 20 2015 12 thousand years ago
but to me it's quite incredible because
it indicates how much the biological
world has changed in such a short period
so then about Lebanon are starting about
eleven and a half thousand years ago the
climate warming really kicked in it for
the end of the last ice age and then
this has led to the last ten thousand
years of quite warm conditions a so
called Halle Halle seen period during
this first of all forests established
then some of my ancestors perhaps
started clearing it producing
agricultural fields and these had lots
of poppies and cornflowers and all sorts
of other arable weeds and then there
were lots of birds that fed on the seeds
both of the crops and of the the weed
seeds of course now conservation name or
agency's a running around a place trying
to make sure that the last few meadows
got these wildflowers and so-called
declining farmland birds are protected
they are only present however in this
area because here of previous human
management of the land and now it's a
horse pasture and might if you like my
own private Nature Reserve each of those
arrows correspond yes to the expectation
X extirpation the loss of populations of
species that were there previously but
each time a new ecosystem came into
existence comprised of species that have
moved in from elsewhere and as time went
on an increasing fraction of these
species arrived had something to do with
humans all of the species living in the
farmlands and the human modified
landscapes were able to move into these
new landscapes because of the habitats
created by humans not in spite of them
so to messages even when biological
processes are happening completely
naturally the species you find in a
biological community or ecosystem at any
one time are a temporary compilation of
species and as time has gone on an
increasing fraction of those changes are
caused by humans rather than what some
people might regard as natural processes
although I consider the impacts of
humans to be natural of course because
we evolved and we're part of the natural
biological system and this isn't just a
quaint old British human modified thing
it's increasingly appreciated how much
the earlier human population in North
America modified the landscape first of
all by exterminating the largest mammals
and then by for example manipulating
fire and it's going on today yesterday I
was enjoying making a terrible video of
anub Anna's hummingbirds which were only
present in the San Francisco area I
understand because you guys have so
kindly planted lots of flowering plants
which is lots of nectar supply and so
they have moved northwards into the
new habitat that you have created this
is just going on all over the planet
species are taking advantage of new
environments created by humans it's not
that suddenly that there was this nature
that was just so that didn't change we
can see how it changed and that humans
have then completely destroyed that
what's actually happened is that we have
added new layers of modification with
lots of species taking advantage of
these modifications just as others are
declining so what we end up having is if
we think back to a sort of pre human
system is that we would have in any
particular region we've got species that
are arriving for example at the end of
the last ice age when the climate
changed lots of the species that would
come in would be attached to large
animals for example that would be moving
across a continent and as those animals
for example beavers coming in might
modify the environment and make habitats
for other species so they spread so this
is a sort of story that would apply
equally 10 million years ago that
there's a various processes of the
leading to species arriving in an area
then all those species that have arrived
they interact with one another to
generate novel biological communities
and as a result of that some of those
species that occurred in the region
previously died out but it is this
dynamic process when seen on timescales
of centuries to millennia and longer it
is this dynamic change that gives us all
of the ecosystems that we currently
enjoy and prized and biological gains
continue this arrival of new species in
fact arguably the arrival of new species
at new locations is probably the fastest
that it is ever been actually on in the
history of life on the land at least and
so what we need to think about is in any
particular place we
live what are the processes giving rise
to these new biological assemblages and
all the diversity that we see in front
of us so the local level by which I
might mean enough a patch of a few acres
for example yes they're going to be the
birth and death of individuals which are
obviously dynamic processes and the
arrivals of individuals and departures
of them that determine how many species
are present and what the diversity is in
a region it's going to be how many
species arrive and colonize the region
how many die out that are extirpated
even though the species still survive
elsewhere and in that in my garden hole
almost all the species that ever lived
there there's were a few exceptions the
large mammoths that we hunted to
extinction for example but virtually all
of the species that were there now that
no longer do they live somewhere else
instead
and so as colonization extinction and
extirpation at a regional level and then
at global levels we've got speciation
and extinction and there's the balance
of these things that determines the
diversity so what I'm going to
concentrate on now is changes in
regional diversity by which I mean well
almost anything that you could consider
some landscapes it could be the Bay Area
for example it could be a county or an
island like Laurel an archipelago like
the Hawaiian Islands so the puzzling
thing is and dove sacks some is has been
really influential in this work putting
together data that illustrates this very
nicely here's the extraordinary thing is
that when you do this and best data I'm
is for plants you find that most regions
as far as we know now contain more
species than they used to a few
centuries ago and almost all of that
change is to do with humans so if we
look at the axis they at the granel the
graph the panel on the right hand side
the the bottom axis is the number of
species before human influence
number of species of plant and on the
axis going up the y-axis we've got the
current species richness the number of
species and you could and that line is
the one-to-one line and although some of
them are very close to the one to one
line each region where the black circles
are mainly European countries or other
European regions the circles are pretty
much all American States they're all
above the one to one line that is to say
states now contain more species of plant
than they used to that doesn't stop you
trying to exterminate them you call
they're invasive and you're horrible
things but that's but but if we just but
I'm a biologist and I I don't find it
very easy to value species by some prior
opinion of whether I ought to like the
mod not and based on that we've actually
got more species in California of plant
at least in California than we used to
we've got more species of mammal in
California than we used to as wealth
goes for snails as well you'll be
pleased to know OC anak Island so that's
about for those continental regions it's
about 20% higher for oceanic islands
it's now on a logarithmic scale because
for various reasons but those blue
circles if actually most Pacific Islands
in particular have got about double the
number of plant species they're used to
some plant species that were did exist
on those islands have now died out and
some of those are global extinctions and
therefore we would might be concerned
about them but if we just count how many
species are there on each Island which
we might imagine could be related to the
ecological resilience of the systems now
then the number of plant species is
empirically doubled and even the people
who hate invasive species the most
accept that that is true and Dan symbol
off he absolutely hates anything foreign
um I'm sure he doesn't really you've
probably got a lovely garden for the I
have no idea what these gardens like but
but if you look at those circles
for Europe the open circles this is from
1200 to the year 2000 a little bit this
is the number of non native mammal
species that have established wild
populations in Europe and we and we're
just I can assure you I can happily tell
you we're just as prejudiced as
Americans and we're trying to
exterminate some of them as well and the
New Zealanders the black triangles they
really are quite good at it and they've
a band they have got very strict import
rules and they've exterminated one or
two so in New Zealand the number of
mammal species with increasing very
rapidly and and now it's leveled off but
we've got all these new mammals over 80
species of mammal in Europe now that
used not to occur there and as far as
anyone knows no native species of mammal
has died out from Europe over the same
same period we've had a net increase in
the number of species so this is not a
kind of biological elite at a state
country level or even continent level it
is not the biological meltdown of the
system diversity that we are sometimes
led to believe of course many of the
species we really care about and both
for a sort of cultural reasons and
because we think they provide ecosystem
services but if a species is we deem a
species to be native and it's common and
widespread our language tends to go to
the value they are to ecosystem
processes their cultural value and why
their decline for example might be so
important to maintaining the biological
systems of any particular region but the
moment any non-native species becomes
common and widespread then of course we
talk about how it changes ecosystems how
it is deleterious so I give you the
House Sparrow which started off in
Western Asia it collides areas it
colonized probably the first
agricultural areas in the Fertile
Crescent
in the middle-east spread into Europe
with the development of Agriculture and
no one really knows a few thousand years
ago would have turned up in the United
Kingdom it was long enough ago and
because so we treated as a native
species but the number of Sparrow
species in Britain in the absence of
human agriculture and human towns and so
on would be zero but it's been there
long enough and it's been declining a
bit over the last few decades have we
put it on the UK Red List of Threatened
Species and we love the mum we probably
you can buy you can get bricks that you
can put in the side of your wall so the
of your house so that they can nest
inside the holes of them you can buy
beetle larvae mealworms that you can put
out in winters and an indeed even during
the summer so they can feed their chicks
on them because there people are worried
that they haven't got enough insect food
any longer
well feeding on insects feed of course
was part of the reason that they were
introduced to North America because it
was entirely fallacious but an argument
that they would control outbreaks of
moths in New York they didn't but they
established and spread right across
North America and since that is more
recent you can buy people don't well
people have mixed opinions of house
sparrows let's just put it that way
the bluebird societies absolutely hate
them because every so often a nasty
foreign english i do they get called
english sparrows they might just leave
now so you can buy traps in fact i
repeat traps that will killed successive
cats excessive sparrows in north america
and although some individuals living in
cities like sparrows in north america
the official line is that they are a
negative influence and though as I said
the bluebird society take a particularly
strong view even though there's no
evidence whatsoever not a shred of it
have looked at the data that house
sparrows are actually driving
mainly Eastern Bluebird populations down
actually Euston Bluebird populations are
increasing because humans have opened up
more of a landscape and how sparrows are
actually declining slightly but this
species is not pre human this species
didn't occur in either of these regions
and it is entirely in our little brains
flat we are distinguishing between them
it's there's no scientific grounds for
thinking that one is a good thing in one
place and a bad thing in another so
faced with all of this new biological
diversity
this is puts us in a very difficult
situation so just to summarize this part
of the talk that regional diversity has
increased for most parts of the world
that we know of for plants that's almost
everywhere we're certainly actually
pretty much is everywhere where there's
good datum of course if you go into the
Central Valley into an area of almond
you can find a few square miles of
almond orchards where clearly the number
of species is considerably lower than it
used to be but a larger areas like the
whole area of California the reverse is
actually true for vertebrates where we
have data again they're not complete
it's also true that most countries and
most islands now have more species of
terrestrial vertebrate than they used to
before we turned up insects we don't
know the answer for almost anywhere in
the world but at least over the last few
decades the United Kingdom has been
gaining species faster than it's been
losing them or actually sorry I'll just
go back to that and say this the picture
here is this is the I I really couldn't
believe it I because I'm because I'm so
trained as everyone is to have this deep
belief in diversity decline everywhere I
decided to go to the Atlantic forest
area of Brazil which has a higher number
of red listed vertebrate species I think
than pretty much any region in the world
Madagascar might
ranked alongside in and there's two
species of birds that are very close to
extinction one of them is a kind of
coração which is extinct in the wild
though it still exists as a sort of sort
of semi wild population and there's
another very small bird that hasn't been
seen for quite a long time although it
went nearly a hundred years between
sightings last time so it may still
exist so when the forest has been
cleared 93 percent of the forest has
been cleared there's a bunch of species
that have declined quite clearly and
some that are endangered and some that
have died out and some that will die out
so this is a real issue but if you're
just counting Birds the cleared land has
then allowed many additional species to
move in so on the left-hand side there
you've got the cattle tyrant that
presumably used to follow South American
megafauna around and they don't live in
forests they only live in sort of quite
open habitats and you can see one on top
of the horses back and another one on
the ground so this is a South American
species that moved into the open areas
and then we've got the colonists with
the cattle egret on the right hand side
which are they're in very large numbers
then the burrowing owls have moved in
and various other species have so even
there the region of the original antique
forest now in total because it still got
some forest that holds most but not all
of the original species and now we've
got a whole series of human modified
habitat that's not just grasslands is
also suburban than the urban areas that
have got a number of additional species
the total number of species at that
regional level has actually gone up so
this is puzzling this is really
important though because if the average
diversity per region has gone up this
means that there are potential long-term
heed Volusia nary consequences because
each of the populations in those new
regions has the potential to evolve
so what we're now seeing is that humans
have become a key process in introducing
species to new areas modifying habitats
that allows new sets of species to move
into areas where they couldn't live
before and then species most of my
research actually is on species
responding to climate change and species
are expanding their ranges into new
areas associated with the changing
climate and these are again producing
new regional biological communities that
evolve and co-evolved
in relation to the physical environment
and one another so this is just the same
picture we had before after you like the
pre the previous one was tough like the
pre human version the human version is
simply that we're adding extra inputs to
the system as well as extra extra
patients and disappearances and I've
drawn the arrows for the arrival of
species deliberately bigger than the
disappearance because the empirical
evidence is that a number of species per
region is going up not down
this all comes to an extraordinary
biological pileup that we're moving more
and more species to more and more
locations where they are then evolving
in fact if we were to exterminate every
one of us instantly today the one real
thing that once all the cities have
disappeared under vegetation and our
agriculture is no longer observable etc
the one change that's really long-term
to the planet that we've already
achieved is to move probably tens of
thousands arguably as many as a hundred
thousand or so species to new parts of
the world where they didn't used to
exist and they will leave descendants in
those new parts of the world that are
eventually going to new lead to the new
biological world
in exactly the same way that the North
American camels moved into South America
when the two South America and North
America were joined by the Isthmus of
Panama and so the vicuna and the South
American camel AIDS of which there are
several extinct species that they came
into existence when they moved into the
new continent and eventually this might
be the signature of diversification
following humans so Pangaea was the
supercontinent that if you asked existed
what about 250 million years or so ago
that split up into the continents that
we currently recognize even when Pangaea
existed as one supercontinent it had a
lot of deserts in it
if you think of Europe and Asia which
obviously one is just semantics that we
treat them as different continents of
course it's one continent but they've
got lots of deserts and coal areas that
are extremely cold during the winter in
Central Asia and so large numbers of the
species in in Western Europe for example
are different from the species in
eastern Asia even though they might be
sort of quite close relatives to one
another well the same would have been
true in Pangaea it wouldn't have been a
region of the world or it wouldn't it
was the world effectively it it wouldn't
have been that easy for a species from a
move from one end of the continent to
another but what we're doing is we're
picking up the planet species and
gradually arguably over a period as
short of a cut short as a couple of
thousand years is removing the
historical biogeography of the planet
and speciation process if you think of
something like the Galapagos Islands is
that one species might arrive in two
different islands and then evolve into
different things on those two islands
and eventually one of the moves back to
the other island and they become
different enough that they can lift the
and this is sort of what we are now
starting to do at a global scale we've
moved the speech lots of species to all
sorts of continents already as those
house sparrows are now on every
continent and lots of oceanic island
eventually we might come back and
they've turned into different species in
each location okay that sounds great
theoretically but are we seeing this
evolutionary response to humans kicking
in well first of all we're seeing a lot
of evolution within populations as we
change the habitats around us many
species take advantage of that
there's colonial populations of
parakeets in northern Europe which have
now been developing larger stronger
beaks because they need to have strong
beasts eat seeds and nuts to get them
through the winter many of those seeds
and nuts being provided on people's bird
tables so here's an example from the
western states of Taylor's Checkerspot
is a very threatened subspecies of you
feed reseda thirdly Edith's Checkerspot
which which if used to occur a Jasper
Ridge down the road now Edith's
Checkerspot this is one subspecies of it
and this subspecies only appears to
survive because the females now choose
to lay their eggs on pantego lancia
later which I should have added a
picture of that so but that's a leaf of
plant a go there this is the plan that
was known as white man's footprints
because it cropped up in everywhere that
humans took Western European origin
populations they took bales of hay as
fodder to North America that had a lot
of the farmland plan the pasture plants
and then they spread across North
America
well Edith's Checkerspot in some
populations have started to lay its eggs
on this plant which is now much more
widespread than the his plants
historically used and so population
after population of species is adjusting
to this new world and this species this
subspecies in particular would probably
have gone extinct already had it not
been for the fact that it has evolved an
adaptation to a human modified
environment in some cases this appears
to be leading to what's termed
ecological speciation where if you get a
new environment coming to existence one
of the existing species that was already
in the region takes advantage of that
new environment becomes adapted to it
and eventually may become so specialized
on the new environment that it's
effectively become a new species so
here's a nice example that Jeff Feder
and his colleagues worked on originally
I think Jeff feeder was a student of guy
bushes who probably started this work
even before and this is a nice example
because we know when apple trees were
introduced to North America though it's
it's unclear when apple trees really
became widespread so most of this story
has happened in the last one to two
hundred years and the although the
earliest apple trees go back a few more
a couple of centuries earlier
they weren't planted very widely until
more recently and this particular fly
those black lines and century if you
sort of squint your eyes he's almost
looks like a spider and so when they get
attacked by something they do this thing
with their wings and you can be that
this is my this is my equivalent of the
bare rub and they sort of wiggle their
wings and they look a bit like a sort of
ferocious spider and so the idea is that
they put their predators off by doing
this anyway they used to lay their eggs
these flies on the hawthorn berries and
the fly grubs would bury into the
Hawthorns and a developed go through the
whole lifecycle associated with Hawthorn
trees now the Apple fly has evolved and
as but can't started to become
genetically distinct and I can go into
on that nauseam about the ways it's
become distinct but effectively it now
has a lifecycle that is completely
associated with apple trees and what's
more three parasitic wasps
I've also only attack the the fly larvae
that are inside the apples so one plant
species has arrived from Europe and
adaptations by North American insects to
it mean that these four insects are now
quite a long way down the pathway to
becoming new species geneticists you
talked to say well maybe their new
species maybe they're not but that was
the whole point of Darwin and Wallace
species don't just suddenly bang come
into existence so sometimes they do is
we'll see they they gradually diverged
and so there's bound to be intermediate
cases but if we took all of the genetic
data physiological data behavioral data
from these flies and we didn't know that
apples had been introduced to North
America then we would probably classify
these for insects as separate species so
the new opportunities created by humans
is generating we're generating so many
new environments across the planet that
large numbers of species are starting to
become adapted to them and over time
centuries millennia tens of millenia
these things if we continue to create
these or maintain these environments
these things would turn into new species
but what we're really seeing and the
most distinctive new species that are
coming into existence are hybrids now
remember this thing how we move lots of
species have moved themselves into human
modified habitat and how much we have
moved species so that previously
geographically separated things are now
have the opportunity to mate with one
another now in the case of the House
Sparrow that is so vilified over here
but loved in Western Europe the House
Sparrow started off in Western Asia it
spread into the Mediterranean Basin
where it met the Spanish Sparrow which
was the sparrow in existence well they'd
rather immodestly
together should we say and um and they
produced some hybrid offspring and this
turned into we don't know this was
probably a few thousand years ago and
the thing in the middle that's got the
brown head that comes from the Spanish
sparrow but a few other words of the
markings that come from the House
Sparrow this thing came into existence
and is now a self-sustaining population
is one of the very few species of bird
in fact that we've got in Europe that
people think is is entirely
geographically restricted to Europe and
so people like this but this is because
we don't it's been here around for a few
thousand years interestingly that when
new hybridization events start to take
place in them over the last 50 to 100
years our immediate reaction has been to
try and exterminate the hybrids so
you've got the lovely case of the
Beefalo well you've got bison x cattle a
degree of hybridization and people are
trying to exterminate cattle genes from
bison populations blaming the over
grazing for example on the sort of
hybrid form when in fact the reason that
I hybrid the over grazing is going on is
entirely because the bison can live in
these hostile environments not because
of the cattle genes so we have a
situation in and so in in Europe we've
had attempts and it's not quite complete
yet to exterminate the North American
ruddy duck because it is hybridizing
with the European ancestor as a sister
species in Europe called the white
headed duck so had this hybridization of
Enders given rise to one of Europe's few
special endemic species now had this
been happening now we undoubtably would
have been trying to kill off the hybrid
instead we've got a new hybrid species
has come into existence and all the
genetic work suggests that this is now
as good a species as any other bird
species
even the existence of one species or a
small number of new species associated
with humans that wouldn't have existed
prior to us implies a slightly different
relationship between us and nature we're
not just the destroyer
we are also indirectly at least a cause
of new things coming into existence and
the story goes on and particularly in
plants so this is a ragwort species of
ragwort originating as a hybrid on on
Vesuvius and it arrived in Britain
traveled around the railway network
which was a bit like sort of the gravels
of railway tracks were a little bit like
volcanic sort of lava flows to colonize
and so this plant species has come into
existence spread round Britain and has
then hybridized with the native species
of senecio giving rise to at least a
couple of additional daughter species
which are now genetically largely
isolated from their parents in fact
about seven it doesn't sound like a vast
number but about seven new species have
coming of plant have come into existence
in Britain through this event this event
of humans moving species from one part
of the world to another hybridization
genetic change subsequently leading to a
distinct new species so top left monkey
flowers MIM ulis you're probably all
familiar with them this part of the
world is a sort of got lots and lots of
species of nebulous but the historic
species so one of the parents came from
South America one came from North
America they met in Scotland they also
made friends they produced though but
their offspring were a bit of a
disappointment because they were
entirely sterile but being plants they
were able actually some of these plants
were able to grow vegetatively so they
spread along streams tides in Scotland
and then one or two of these plants had
a nasty genetic accident one day and
doubled their chromosome number and what
had previously been a sterile form
turned into a sexually reproducing
species so now we
got a couple of populations of monkey
flower in Scotland that effectively are
a new species and because the chromosome
number has doubled they can't reproduce
with either parent any longer they are a
new species and be in existence for very
long but they are a new species so we've
got about seven species of this type in
in Britain that have arisen since 1700
I'm not going to try and explain the
left-hand graph at the bottom but using
various molecular genetic methods you
can try and estimate what the historic
rate of speciation will allow and then
I've tried to do this for plants in
Britain over the last 300 years if you
like for the Anthropocene speciation
rate so don't worry what the axis is but
it's a logarithmic scale so two units
along there is a hundredfold difference
in speciation rate and in Britain the
plant speciation rate appears to be
about a hundred times faster than it
seems to have been historically whether
one call considers the average across
all plants black dots or for most
rapidly evolving types of plant which
are the open circles so the speciation
rate appears to have to be higher than
and possibly historically unprecedented
and over the same period amazingly in
Europe we only have documented at least
I'm sure there must be some more but
then there'll be lots more new species
that haven't been documented yet we've
only got one species of plant that's
become extinct as an entire species over
the same period so bizarrely it Britain
has contribution to the world over the
last 300 years to been increase the net
number of species in the planet so at
the very least we can't ignore the
speciation rate but eventually the tens
to hundreds of thousands of species that
we will end up spreading around the
world are going to diverge into new
species in then
homelands and this is one of your
favorites
the yellow starthistle well some
beekeepers like it because it's
sometimes about the only thing that's
got any nectar on it and actually the
butterfly folk quite liked it because
it's a good nectar source as well so
yellow starthistle has already diverged
and it's about 50% sterility
when crossed as Daniel Montesinos and
colleagues showed that accidentally they
they it wasn't there the purpose of
their research they just sort of found
it out by crossing things for fun almost
and they found out that there's more or
less 50% sterility already between the
original European population and the
Californian population of this plant and
and this is just within 100 or so years
so as things evolved under local
conditions and just diverged eventually
you know it might take many centuries
before this process is complete even
millennia but eventually these species
have been spread around the world in
different locations are going to turn
into new species and this in the long
run is likely be the major cause of
speciation and by my back of envelope
calculations I admit that I reckon this
is going to lead to at least a doubling
of a number of species on the planet
so it's at least worthy of asking the
question of whether we are generating
effectively a six mass origination it
shouldn't be dismissed as a possibility
it doesn't mean that we stop caring
about things that are ending but that
the rate at which new things are coming
into existence is fast enough that it is
not a trivial thing we should ignore and
so much of the biological diversity of
this around us wherever we live is stuff
that's just arrived and therefore we
interact with it anyway and we should be
interested in those new ecosystems so
the global diversity change
is a balance of gains and loss and you
can think of that as speciation and
extinction at the moment almost
certainly the total extinction rate is
higher than the total speciation rate
certainly for animals that seems almost
certainly the case but eventually these
lines are going to cross and this
question of when the speciation rate
will event that will be higher than the
extinction rate we don't know the answer
to that but what we do know is that
we're living in this world of huge
ongoing change associated with human
activities in which there are biological
gains that are human driven as well as
losses the Anthropocene if you like or
the Anthropocene depending on your
pronunciation preference it is different
it is a new biological world calling it
a new epoch helps highlight that and we
are part of this system and we can tun
pick it we just got to get used to we
cannot unpick the human effected and
then non-human affected the co2 in the
atmosphere is absolutely everywhere the
pH of the ocean has changed so we just
can't say go to any ecosystem and say
this is a human altered bit this isn't
I'm going to fix it and turn it back
into a non changed system it's it's
impossible the other thing is that the
human population is still growing and
whilst in my country and dare I say it
yours
people are not short of nutrition this
still is the case for some parts of the
world and so the total food consumption
of the planet is probably by humans is
probably going to roughly double and we
need the production systems that are
going to deliver that and so we're going
to continue to live with the world of
change we can't just sort of put our
heads in the sand and hope the change is
going to go away and as the world does
continue to change
we've got to stop treating nature like a
sort of old master that we've got to
restore back to some magic actually sort
of rose-tinted imaginary system that
might have well choose your
date as to when your favorite period is
this is what you might call ecological
baseline thinking what was the system
here how do we get back to it
so in this lovely case this was a fresco
I think it was it in an abbey or
Cathedral or Church or somewhere in in
Spain I think and it was looking a bit
tatty so this very kind volunteer lady
who's perhaps either their artistic
skills were not so brilliant or their
eyesight was slightly fading but they
tried to restore it back to what it was
and it turned out not to be such a great
idea but but we shouldn't imagine that
nature nature is a dynamic thing of
gains and losses it's always been the
case and so we shouldn't imagine that
nature was in some state that we've got
to restore it to in fact if you think of
a baseline of any baseline any date you
Wed choose all biological gains which we
seen through time have continued on that
again and again again all gains up to
that time are considered good and so are
all losses up to that time because
that's the system at the time of the
baseline the moment the baseline date
has passed all changed since their gains
and losses all considered bad because
they are departures from that state so
we have to work and think really embrace
this idea we're working with a dynamic
system and it and that no change is not
an option that's on the table it never
actually was and but what we've got a
choice is about potential directions and
rates of change and then we have to
think carefully about the extent to
which we think new things whether there
are new species like Spartan aranga
curve um whether these are somehow bad
an American of vigorous American species
or spartina was brought to bitten up to
Britain in the eighteen
hundreds to try and stabilize some of
the marshland on the south coast of
England and it was fairly successful but
when it reproduced with a resident
poultry British species of spartina in
fact their offspring which then
undertook genetic changes again was
became Spartina anguk oh that first
spread round the coastline of Britain
and was extremely successful in why
people had introduced these plants in
the first instant in stabilizing
intertidal muds and it's now spread back
around the world and there's a spartan
around here I believe which some of the
rare rails are actually nesting in so
we've got to accept that changing
biodiversity is about games as well as
losses and it's always has been and when
we think about when something's new
turns up new in a new location and
thereby changes the system a bit to what
extent do we really mind about that
change when is it really causing a
long-term problem versus a short time
perception that the system is changing
and that we don't like change so we
can't go back
we can't unpick the planet and my would
urge you to fight what might be
considered genuine loss the termination
perhaps of species that can no longer be
available to contribute to the world's
ecosystems in the future but not to
fight change per se because that is the
way that the biological world responds
to in environmental perturbation nature
didn't stop when we turned up ecological
and evolutionary processes went into
overdrive because we changed the
environment so fast so you can wake up
now
and thank you very much for your
intention and I'll just leave you with
that what I call my shameless plug but
but also three questions but there are
many questions related our new species
worse than old ones are we happy do we
think this is a good idea that we are at
we might potentially generating a new
acceleration of diversity and should we
actually think about trying to promote
speciation we want to try and stop
extinction is it as legitimate for us to
think about generating new species that
would be useful to us I bet every single
one of you today has eaten one of those
human created species many of our major
crops are new species that have come
into existence so new species are not
bad per se we just need to go and think
about what are the circumstances in
which we wish to encourage this new
diversity versus try and maintain what
we had previously
so thank you very much indeed for your
patience
ah I'm not surprised the first question
that Kevin Kelly picked up is from
Morgan who asks we tend to think of
biodiversity as inherently valuable is
this new biodiversity is is it as quote
valuable is the old and is the number of
species the right metric to look at okay
so is it as valuable well given my
aunt's what I said right at the end
about the number of crop plants like
wheat for example that we eat species
per species on average the new species
are more valuable to us than the old
ones well now in terms in terms of
nutritional input and so so a lot of
these new species is so if you not all
them a truly new species but if you lop
go through the world's hundred top crops
a really substantial percentage of them
I won't try and quote the percentage of
my top of my head but it's well over
half of them are actually at these
partial hybrids between two or more
previously existing species since we're
looking for species to be able to
prosper we're talking about a sort of a
rich ecosystem are these ritual
ecosystems in the same trims of riches
we would have regarded them as rich
before they well they're different
Nature doesn't do value judgments we do
actual values I'm I'm trying to yes I am
trying to shift the values because if we
look at that think of that time sequence
in my whole that each time a new
ecosystem has come into existence at
least five times they're the humans that
were around at the time interacted with
and used resources from that ecosystem
with that particular set of species and
so it's there's nothing therefore
intrinsically less valuable about a new
mixture of species in a new ecosystem
than an old one it is entirely possible
that a new ecosystem will be less useful
to us as humans and it is entirely
possible that it will be more useful to
us on the whole over the planet's
surface we have made yeah this is not a
biodiversity conservation thing but our
argument but on the whole we have made
ecosystem more amenable to our use more
of the world's land surface is producing
food for us for example so that we can
make things though better or worse from
a human perspective as a whole and very
often when we make a place better from
one human perspective we make it worse
from another one so we have many choices
about food production versus some other
let's say a national park versus food
production well we as humans would like
some balance between these things both
of these are important to us but the
fact that they're altered systems all of
them from the National Park with climate
change etc through to the agricultural
system doesn't then by definition make
them worse in my human is this new
subfield of ecology of novel ecosystems
yes that's right it's poly novel all the
way back and that the historic depths of
our altering of the planet surface is
much longer than most of us recognized
so I think the story is now pretty
familiar to a large number of people of
how many large vertebrates particularly
large mammals have been exterminated by
humans I think at last count it was
something like 178 or something but and
these are of the really big vertebrates
and these would have completely
transformed the vegetation so of course
had we been here 10,000 years that well
say 15,000 years ago had we been here
today and there had been no humans here
there would be elephants relatives of
various type right around us snake just
go to the La Brea Tar Pits to see the
sort of fauna you would have so the fact
that we removed this meant that ten
thousand years ago the vegetation
started to develop without these large
animals go to Africa you see what
elephants do to the vegetation well that
was happening right over the world so
the vegetation that we had everywhere
was already altered by humans and then
we done all sorts of other things so we
shouldn't think that until very recently
we were living in this world pristine
world that had not been altered by
humans the reality is we are today
changing at a rapidly rate and sometimes
alarmingly we are changing things at a
rapid rate but we are changing an all
system that was already been changed by
humans not something that sort of was
natural out there before a pre human
existence the other metric that comes to
mind is more life can be measured in
terms of more kinds of creatures more
species more life can be measured in
terms of biomass just there's more
living stuff going on there's also bio
abundance which is you're looking at the
just the population level of certain
species that you care about because
increasing biodiversity generally lead
to borne more biomass and as
generally lead you where you might call
more bio abundance so the the jury is to
some extent out I think on some of those
questions there must be different
Englishes
yes the the key importance of biological
diversity so when you do experiments and
you put one species in a system let's
say it's a one species of plant and you
grow it under certain conditions and you
vary those conditions you find that one
species of plant kind of does okay it
produces certain man you add two three
four five species the productivity of
the vegetation tends to go up but once
you get to dozens of species then it
kind of plateaus out so to some extent
you've we've got more species than we
need but where you find that lots of
species matter is when the system
changes because they provide the
resilience not through any kind of great
global biological pre thing that's not
how nature works of course but the very
fact that there are vast numbers of
species there means that however the
system changes it increases the
likelihood that some of those species
are capable of dealing with the new
situation and that is why I emphasize
going back to the first question is why
I emphasize the species quite a lot
though it's shorthand for genetic
diversity within species a number of
species number of general families etc
of animals and plants because the more
different types of things we still got
somewhere in the global system might not
be within the geographic area where they
used to live but as long as they exist
somewhere then they're the building
blocks from which new change can develop
and we don't know how humans are going
to have modified the planet in the next
say thousand years but we do know that
pretty much all of the biological world
is going to be comprised of the
descendents of today's species even if
some of them are hybrids etc and some of
them have evolved but they're still
going to be descendents of today's
things so keeping those species in
existence maximizes that in my thinking
anyway that very long term
Brazilians whereas if you think about
modern ecosystem services the modern
benefits we get from a patch of land
well that might be provided by one
species of crop just as well as by
thousands of plants I want to focus on
and the difference between ocean islands
and continents as you mentioned the 10%
loss of bird species yep and my sense is
that most of those bird species were
ocean island species yep seabirds
basically loss of bird species on the
continents Eurasia and Americas okay so
so some of them have been seabirds but
high proportion of the species that have
died out from oceanic islands were
actually terrestrial species but their
worlds were very small so the oceanic
islands so to get to an oceanic Island
you need to fly a long distance if
you're a bird and of course that's how
the original ancestors of the hawaiian
honeycreepers arrived in the hawaiian
islands they were regular finches from
eastern asia are close to the rose
finches and they colonized the Hawaiian
Islands then he evolved into a great
diversity of different thing amazing but
nearly all of the species of bird that
have been documented as having gone
extinct or deduced must have been from
analysis of fossils nearly all of them
were these Island birds and for this
from the surviving Island birds we know
that there are critical traits
associated with them which meant they
were susceptible well first of all many
of them were terrestrial and flightless
or nearly flightless because they had
evolved into an island they didn't find
that there were rats and cats and
primates like humans around and so the
ability to fly an escape from predators
was less important they became more and
more sedentary and of course then when
humans and cats and rats etcetera did
turn up then they were
sitting ducks and and so so they were
susceptible to this arrival of predators
the other thing is that very often that
this is the key problem in the Hawaiian
Islands at the moment is that mosquitoes
weren't present and even though every so
often bird malaria would have arrived
through migrant Birds arriving in
Hawaiian Islands the vectors were not
present so maintaining a defense against
the disease involves some metabolic cost
just like flying does and so eventually
most of these island birds ended up
evolving not to be disease resistant
when the vectors and the diseases
arrived they were susceptible so these
island species have evolved if you like
they're a subset of the biological world
and when they mixed up again with the
rest of the world species they died out
because they were effectively not
capable of dealing with continental
predators and diseases and you could say
well that's a terrible shame it would be
a lovely it's lovely to have a few
examples of these things at least from a
scientific and a cultural perspective to
enjoy but in terms of the future of
biological world of birds you know birds
are good at flying and virtually all
birds on the continents are disease
resistant and that is why they've been
this particular group of dinosaurs has
been so successful for the last fifty
five million years and and it's going to
continue to be the case it just turned
out that mammals were better at doing
things on the ground than the birds and
they've exterminated them from oceanic
island so could I unpick the world and
return all of these species well
actually I would I think it would be
fascinating to see all of them but do I
think it's changing the on timescale of
millions of years do I think it's
changing the trajectory of bird
evolution in any important way well no I
don't because I think that it's going to
be the continental birds that have these
capabilities that are going to be the
future that's where the future
descendants of birds are going to come
from so those axes
plant population the species on places
like New Zealand there's double and
that's proof of oceans and it sounds
like the animal species have been
introduced from you go to why are you
staying a hotel you hear all kinds of
birds they have to be the Midwestern
birds I reckon you know there's a Robin
there's a cardinal these various
creatures and the honey creepers are way
up in the top of the mountains where
nobody goes because that's where they
can get away from the mosquitoes that
are killing them with malaria so what
just happened the biodiversity of Hawaii
in New Zealand and these other islands
has increased places like Ascension
Island they've gone from almost nothing
to quite a lot of introduced species but
the overall Pacific biodiversity of a
few included all the various islands and
all various endemic species they had
that sort of oceanic diversity of Island
species has gone down now it sounds like
what we're pointing out is that the
species that went down we're pretty
defenseless species they're not
continental species they're not they're
not yeah that's right
but sometimes they just have a specific
defect now many environments mentalists
are a bit nervous when we start talking
about new genetic technologies and so on
but if you want to save the Hawaiian if
you want to save the hawaiian
honeycreepers well it's alright guys
there's 10,000 odd species of bird that
are resistant to malaria they've all got
genes for malaria resistant well I'd get
a captive population of hawaiian
honeycreepers of many species as one can
and pop these resistance genes on these
so it doesn't seem to be anything wrong
with them otherwise as bird species
these honey creepers it's just that they
can't deal with this disease it would be
more of a challenge to turn a ton of
Kiwi into an albatross that is it that
it's certainly the case
but in terms of the general trends what
I'm hearing is that the species that are
since kind of dead ends they're really
good locally but it's thinking in a
global context got all over for them
yeah but there are these global species
there's human Anthropocene Pangaea is
one kind of the UMaine the species that
were spreading that are prospering
sometimes against our best efforts to
keep them from doing so
our evolutionarily very robust yeah so
in a sense the general resilience and
robustness of life on Earth has gone up
you could argue that yeah and I think I
couldn't handle it and once you can't
handle it they're doing fine thank you
and they're multiplying yeah I think I
think it is good news uh-huh I'm going
to add one caveat I'm gonna shoot myself
in the foot here my caveat is that
that's under current conditions and I
think when we're talking about island
vs. continental Birds I think that on
the whole that's quite clear but some of
the species are very successful at the
moment if humans change the way that we
manage the world very competitive
in a few centuries time we're going to
be getting our food in very different
ways and we just with disgust and we may
be growing our meat in factories rather
than having animals out in fields mainly
and and so on and so the things that are
very successful now and appear robust
may actually decline again and that's
why I think having so many additional
species out there is an advantage
because that provides opportunities for
whatever new conditions we create that
something will take advantage of them
the question everyone has
here's one from Maloney that's the piece
of that that's very changeable the
carbon nitrogen so on matter in terms of
overall ecological process he's driving
selection pressures and this is an area
focused on how big a deal is climate
change in all this it's an it's an
enormous challenge we're going to go but
even for the most
modest time it changed scenarios we're
gonna go back to conditions which on
average across the planet we went to
seen for probably three million years
the carbon dioxide Atmos in the
atmosphere is probably already high and
it's been for that length of time and
he's headed to be the highest for at
least ten and probably 20 or so million
years well carbon dioxide might sound
obviously it Sidda Faiz the ocean and
there's all the coral reefs we're
concerned about so that so that's a
major transformative thing and think of
it every plant on the earth apart from a
few parasitic ones is it's using carbon
dioxide in its photosynthesis that's and
so the relative ability of every plant
species on the planet to grow every
plant individual on the planet has been
changed already and it's going to
continue to be changed so this is an
enormous perturbation to the system and
the zoo so we don't really know exactly
how the system is going to respond but
they caveat there but though so Saroyan
you insane DUP to the fact that we
should minimize our greenhouse gas
emissions and and and if it's gonna
happen that we make it as slow as
possible but the reality is that if you
look diversity across the planet's
surface
the there's higher diversity in places
that are both hotter and often
particularly places at a moister as well
and as the temperature is going up and
on average not everywhere I know that
California has big droughts etcetera
but on average precipitation on the
planet is going up because they when it
gets hotter more water evaporates from
the ocean and it comes down somewhere
and so with a slightly wetter and
decidedly warmer planet surface the
expectation but not yet demonstrated
really the expectation is that diversity
will increase slightly and a planetary
level we certainly have evidence that is
happening
in quite substantial parts of the
temperate zone but it's not yet possible
to say that this is a truly global
phenomenon so it's so this is a kind of
it's an uncomfortable reality but so
he's simultaneously you can have the
average diversity increasing but you can
still have loads of species as a
restrict did the Sierra Nevada or
somewhere dying out and so you can these
two things are simultaneously possible
that the average local diversity can go
up but that the total number of species
on the earth could come down as a result
of climate change that is my expectation
and so given that species can't come
local diversity can change up and down
rather easily and species can't come
back rather easily I would suggest we go
for a low-carbon option rather than a
high one here here so it sounds like one
of the things you're pointing out this
is all about rates so rate of climate
change as against rate of speciation
let's say you know how rapidly can these
various plants and animals and microbes
and whatnot evolve to manage the rate of
climate change that we're bringing about
climate change
well there's already I can't answer your
question because we have particular
examples but we don't have enough
examples that we could quantify what
rates are higher than which so we kind
of do in some senses that on the land at
least hmm the rate at which species are
spreading towards the poles mm-hmm at
the pole woods so imagine the geographic
distribution of a species and it's got
one edge of the geographic distribution
is closer to the pole for the cold edge
if you like and then the hot edge that's
close to the equator empirically what
we're seeing in quite large numbers of
species both insects and vertebrates
we're seeing that the northern edge or
the poleward edge is spreading towards
the pole
faster than we are getting the retreat
at the southern edge slightly which is
consistent with this idea that average
local diversity would tend to go up
slightly now what we're seeing is that
the northern margins that are spreading
in the North temperate zone which are
spreading towards the poles we are
seeing evolution as species move because
any individual that colonizes further
north successfully is likely because
it's a good colonist in some way it's
likely to be a non-random member of the
population so most of the species that
people actually examined in detail is
showing some evolutionary changes at
their expanding polewards boundary the
fact that we've got any retreat
indicates that those populations at that
have died out have not evolved fast
enough to keep up with the changes
because effectively local extinction or
species extinction you can think of as a
failure of evolution to move fast enough
to keep up with the new conditions so so
both of these things are true think some
things are evolving fast enough to keep
keep up there are clearly places within
the distributions of species that are
not keeping up and can I say what
percentage you're keeping up on one no
but no but no biologist in the world can
I think give a clear answer on that yet
well I think conservationists so mixed
feelings so I've had I've had a little
bit of one or two sort of hate messages
exciting quite extreme uh chai I like to
think I might be quite wrong but I like
to think exclusively from people who
haven't actually read the book
in fact if that led to one famous
conversation over a dinner over dinner
which involved one of the chief
scientists of one of the UK's leading
conservation organizations
and we'd been I I had wanted to try and
sort of close it down because it seemed
a bit rude to having this argument well
it was getting a little bit heated about
non-native species across half a dozen
other people and being polite British
person I didn't think we should be doing
that and and and eventually being in
fact in truth completely implied I said
well why don't you just read the bloody
book because actually I try to present
the fact that we have got bosses from
various sources but we have also got
gained and we should take these two
things in consideration simultaneously
and if it is legitimate for us to stop
declines in diversity why isn't it also
legitimate for us to foster increases in
diversity
wherever that diversity comes where do
you see that so nuts or practically I
mean the wonderful bottom line was fight
loss not a change yes and what is that
how does that play out in terms of
actual conservation on the ground well I
think the conservationists are accepting
that but conservation is most
conservationists on now and are
accepting that we are living in a weird
period of rapid change
we can't wish it away but the problem is
if you do away with your baseline which
is deeply flawed but if you do away with
that how do you measure change what's
your goal in class from this is it is it
is already conservation so I think okay
so I think that's quite a lot of people
saying okay well we can carry on doing
this for a while and they know that in a
century or so it's not going to be
defensible what they're doing but they
don't know what the alternative is
and and I'm arguing and actually part
the reason I got into the whole of this
thing in the first instant is that I saw
more and more resource and effort of
volunteers being spent on trying to keep
things as they were when it's clear the
moment you thought on a timescale beyond
a few decades
that ultimately it was going to fail and
it was going to be wasted effort and
that that then is the real challenge how
do we set our goals now for me I like to
think that we should think in the modern
politics is maybe I should keep my mouth
shut um but but the challenge is in the
modern world where the biological
systems are dynamic we have to think on
increasingly large-scale international
scales more of a problem in Europe
actually than it is here because we're
split into ridiculous number of
countries but in so because each country
sees its own species as its problem and
and Spain doesn't want to give Britain a
population of Iberian lynx the most
endangered species of cat arguably on
the planet because it's their Ling's
the Brits don't want the Spanish lynx
because it didn't occur in Britain
before nasty foreign lynxes actually it
did about 150 thousand years ago its
ancestors but they've forgotten that so
but so what Brits are going to do is to
reintroduce if they possibly can there's
a whole group of people working on it
now to reintroduce the Eurasian Lynx
which and spend a lot of money on doing
this um when actually it's about the
most widespread and least endangered cat
species on the planet now for me given
that we're living with dynamic systems
why not put your effort and money into
the species that's genuinely endangered
rather than imagining putting links back
in the Home Counties is going to make
the world somehow good again
Persis it's the beginning so and there's
a 10,000 year time frame which is one we
like around here for conservation
basically says drop the word that what
we were talking about is life and
answers yeah and we sort of got a pretty
good idea of what we mean by life we're
still figuring out what we mean by
enhance or serve servers life survives
from storage hey you know it's in the
Bible there's a the term that is used
about what Indians did in this state
oh it's tending the wild there's a
wonderful book called tinning the wild
for basically the native population here
before Europeans showed up gardened the
whole state and it was incredibly rich
both for them and for any other species
that we're here so there's tending the
wild life enhancing perspective seems to
gain the long term value that you're
pushing for through basically taking an
evolutionary perspective rather than
just an ecological perspective yes
obviously all one but thinking like an
evolutionist as well as an ecologist
seems to change what we mean by
conservation is that your view
I definitely think evolution is not in
the minds of most conservationists who
tend to think it operates too slowly for
it to be relevant well yes but you go
and go and ask any doctor about rate of
evolution and the bugs that are becoming
resistant to things
ask any agriculturalists about the rate
of evolution and how long a particular
herbicide or insecticide lasts before
there are spies of species of pests
which are able to live in this
environment and in the agricultural
secta they reckon that new resistant
varieties for example and new
insecticides herbicides are likely to
have a shelf life of around about a
decade or two before there are enough
things that are resistant there is no
long that they have to have replaced it
and so so if you think ok this is a
particular situation and it's clear when
evolution effectively allows a species
to live in the environment where it
otherwise couldn't in other words where
there's a particular chemical laid down
now if you step back and think what are
we doing to the planet's surface as a
whole well we've modified it absolutely
everywhere we've modified the atmosphere
climate and it is absolutely inevitable
that everything is pretty much evolving
because every population of every
species apart from a few clonal things
contains genetic variation it is
extraordinarily unlikely that every
individual in all of these populations
is equally successful or unsuccessful
under the new conditions as the
environment changes so more or less
almost by definition populations are to
be involving in response to the human
modification to the environment direct
and indirect and what we don't we don't
have a good I can't draw your frequency
distribution of the rates of these
evolutions because we don't know but
what we have now a current state of
knowledge is we have a large sample of
examples where evolution has taken place
both in the heavily modified environment
from inside hospitals agricultural field
fisheries where fish are maturing at
younger smaller sizes for example under
hunting which we complain things like
Taylor's Checkerspot etc fear
butterflies in my own meadow at home
where we know that they have involved
responses to human changes to the
environment in a way that looks is is
clearly Scott the sick
nature of humanity and now if we go back
to your nice example of the original
population here and the human population
that came into this part of the world
and and I'll try and choose my language
carefully here but I don't mean to
offend anywhere I'm trying to describe
something has happened it's that first
of all the humans came in and they
exterminated the largest beasts they
were capable of doing this I think it
depended in though in the region yeah so
yeah so I was wonderful going to going
and seeing some of these traps in South
America that they use that the American
that the serve Aboriginal populations
there still have knowledge of and and
it's just amazing with this sort of bed
of spikes to catch large cats was free
frankly actually but think of they've
exterminated the largest animals and
they have been hunting gathering and as
you say then you get this sort of system
that that become sort of somewhat
stabilized and you described it in a
fairly idealized way that's how the
system ended up and but originally it
probably it would have taken quite a
long time for all of those species to
assemble in their new distributions with
the management as it's going on now I
was whilst you were saying that I was
thinking funnily enough if does that
tower a tower over there wherever it is
that and I walked up there through
people's gardens this is what I was
seeing hummingbirds and all sorts of
other things and lots of exotic flowers
and this is the new biological world I
sometimes think that in a few centuries
we're going to be conserving suburban
Gardens because they're going to be very
unusual collections of species but but
the collections of species that you talk
about this sort of idealized we're way
of human
living with nature this came into
existence gradually as the species that
could live in those places
gradually arrived and became part of
these new biological communities but you
shouldn't forget that when then they got
horses and then they got guns hmm
they changed the way they hunted and
this is happened all over the world so
very often these idealized systems
living in harmony with nature the moment
you give people an additional technology
they use it and they end up doing all
sorts of things that we might then
regard as a degradation of the system so
the bizarre thing that we now have to do
is to contemplate we are now if you like
sufficiently well-versed in the entire
planet and how it is changing that we
can start to think about what is this
future world we want we're going to have
many more technologies and things we
could do to the planet surface then we
actually want to do and it is the
choices between these alternative
futures that we're going to have to end
up making and although many
conservationists are upset by some of
the things I'm saying but not others to
my mind we have to have this discussion
because there's no point thinking of
ourselves as just the destroyer we're
part of the world system and we are
going to continue to be the part of the
world system for as long as we care
about it until our extermination
whenever that might be and because we
are part of that system we therefore
have a choice of these futures and we
may choose some ways and not others but
thinking about how the system actually
operates is essential if we are going to
make long-term choices that are not
throwing away our environmental dollar
on on approaches to conservation that in
the long term might fail I think because
you're describing how life is blending
in with human behavior yes and it sounds
like the future is human behavior
learning the plan
in with life yes that's right and and I
imagine that pretty much all human
societies actually have some degree
despite our capacity to destroy things
most human societies most religions I'm
a religious myself but most religions
have embedded within them assent some
sense of nature and caring for it even
if actually the practice of that human
population has been to destroy much more
than it protected and because this
caring exists
wherever enthusiasm for interest
wherever it comes from whether it's part
of our evolutionary history or whatever
wherever it comes from it does mean that
human societies do have some sense of
caring about nature and very often the
arguments about what nature does for us
that has become common parlance in
conservation so-called ecosystem goods
and services that but actually this
often kind of misses the point because
most of the people who are arguing about
the great benefits of nature
for Humanity they're doing it actually
because they're trying to they're trying
to persuade finance Shias who might not
actually care about the environment but
the reason that they're doing this work
and they're trying to persuade the
finances is not because of the economic
benefits or their or the value to him an
humanity if you look at talk to these
people and their care about nature
actually they're by large doing it just
because they loved the stuff
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]